Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number,
that number is two one nine two. David P.
Guys, I'm really taking a lot of
hits this week. I was criticized
for saying that Oprah is to some degree
responsible for Dr. Oz because she's the one
who brought him to the public and someone said
that that's racist. How dare I accuse a black
woman of that? And now I am being criticized
because I did not issue a Ramadan greeting
on Monday, I guess. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Good morning, Wendy from California
with regards to Monday's show greeting, you know,
welcoming back from Passover. And then it's like,
Oh yeah, and Easter. Wasn't it also Ramadan? I
don't know. I would like to believe that you're
not myopic and that your inclusive and
that oh, because of inclusive inclusion
that leads to about objectivity. Um, last week
I was concerned because you thought the Native
Americans didn't put up enough resistance, and
Speaker 1: now I don't even know what the hell
she's talking about there. So the second
part I felt the Native Americans didn't put
up enough resistance. I never said that.
OK, that's completely out of this world.
But I guess the problem is on Monday, I
said, Hey, hope everybody had a good Passover
or a good Easter. It's good to be back. And I
didn't. I didn't mention Ramadan. So here's the
deal. I don't know what the hell is going on
as far as religion goes. I know about Passover
because I'm culturally Jewish. OK, so that's
why I know about Passover. I know about Easter,
because it's a federal holiday. It's on every
calendar, OK? I don't know about anything else
going on. So if someone tells me it was Ramadan,
it's not because I don't in particular not care
about Islam. I just, I just don't know. March 2nd,
I looked up March 2nd was Ash Wednesday. I had no
idea. I didn't mention it. I just I don't know if
it's like if the stock markets open and whatever.
On Friday, I notice the stock market was close and
I was like, Why is it closed? I looked it up. Oh,
it's Good Friday because it's Easter. That's
the only reason I even figured it out. You know
this this coming week, this Sunday is Orthodox
Easter. I had no idea. I looked it up and I found
it. April 29th is Laylat Alucarda. I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly. That's that's a Muslim
holiday. I don't know anything about. There's
no let's not read in with malice to things that
are just really no big deal. OK, everybody relax.
All right. I'm not trying to be disrespectful to
anybody. Everybody's welcome to watch this show on
any day, regardless of what holidays are going on
on the bonus show today. Netflix has lost
viewers for the first time in 10 years.
Their stock has absolutely crashed. I lost a bunch
of money because I've owned Netflix stock for a
really long time. I had forgotten about it and
yesterday I guess I lost 40 percent. OK, we will
talk about what's going on with Netflix. Omarosa
Manigault Newman has been awarded over a million
bucks in legal fees from the Trump campaign.
Will she ever actually get it? And Senate
Democratic candidate Tom McDermott smoked pot in
a political ad to celebrate yesterday, being 420.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show. Don't miss it. Sign up at Join Patricof.